I went to the gym the other day and I
wait train for the first time you work
out your legs so hard right when you
start to sit down it looks like you're
torquing oh I apologize that was my
twerk face
[Music]
Oh what is going on YouTube man recently
I read an interesting article man have
you ever heard about this one this one's
easy a man with a name D 2nd to attend
the University of Arizona has been
standing around campus with signs saying
that women deserve rape mother
well B's SQL view points that were
[ __ ] stupid so let's go ahead and talk
about that women deserve to be raped
because they wear shorts [ __ ] unit in
Arizona it's hot
what did you expect their attire to be
in a hundred fifty degree weather
selfish [ __ ] [ __ ] it's so hot
over there even Satan be like it's hot I
can't believe they're provoking it by
wearing shorts seduce you if a dancer
that's a survival tactic let me I said
why do they got a couple em cells under
400 agree whether because you take the
challenge in every time you see some
legs you had a lot of sexual tension
buddy just to be turned off by some
booty shorts here let me help you out
this is what you need to do go home get
yourself a box of tissue paper I have
the bottle of Vaseline and tell yourself
silly till you fall asleep what this
[ __ ] be like come out shortly
too revealing
have you seen certain parts that don't
mean [ __ ] because tyrs be like god damn
look at those titties dangle but now you
can do is be like oh yeah you know
that's free porn out right you could
touch your ass come on way to balance
and that shit's free baby but you one
lucky when I was a kid watching porn was
like the most difficult task on earth
you ever tried downloaded porn on a 56k
modem that [ __ ] would take so long by
the time you finish you don't even want
it anymore not sleepy so pity tonight
twelve percent three percent how to go
backwards it's because men are visual so
it's their fault
y'all not to be so [ __ ] stupid oh my
god really what visual watching
visualize yourself tough [ __ ] on how to
eat I was
for you to show me that cause-and-effect
study where shows that a women being
raped is directly correlated to what
they went Nazi what you say it's not
because the guy is a piece of [ __ ] is
because she deserves me [ __ ]
take the rusty spoon and stab yourself
how's that you wouldn't be saying this
if the situation was reversed my friend
if it gets hot you think up your shirt
to wear short maybe you deserve to get
something shut up yes to watch a buff at
breakfast use your booty hole and I stop
for his dip and see you still use that
fat for a purchase never mind you
realize that short shorts get you horny
I'd hate to see what happens when you
see a little cleavage why is this
[ __ ] have no manners I'm
pointing at everybody with his pants I
bet your bottom captain's call you
Pinocchio cuz your dick donut huh
whatever she's not hot Oh goddamnit the
problem that we have is that you said
that certain women deserve to be raped
when you stand them with a sign saying
that women deserve to be sexually and
violently abused because of what they
wear shows how utterly stupid and
undeserving you are to be living in this
society
that's faith metallo prove that you're
absorbing men from their sacred criminal
actions because of what because they
dressed a certain way because men can't
help it because they were visually
provoked are you [ __ ] stupid let me
dump this stupid statement down even
more women who dress a certain way
deserve to be raped because men by
default are so [ __ ] stupid that they
can't control themselves you know what I
love you [ __ ] logic because the next
time you're about a woman getting raped
I'll make sure to let her know that it's
her fault for being born a woman in fact
you should rather go in hide is when an
angry mob kidnaps us speak something up
yes I'll make sure to let you know they
are visually stimulated them you deserve
to be raped she want to go straight to
dessert Tech please
[Music]
uh-huh welcome to Sigma Theta Delta ray
pehoe hey thanks a lot with all of it